[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mal mit Heinz
Wolf uns marietas lomka guten Abend
schloss Meseberg das Gästehaus der
Bundesregierung gefiel auch schon
Theodor Fontane auf seinen Wanderungen
durch die Mark Brandenburg er nannte es
das Zauberschloss bei der Klausurtagung
erinnert das allerdings eher an Thomas
Manns Zauberberg ein Sanatorium für eine
Koalition die an ihren Animositäten
krankt die Süddeutsche Zeitung hat
nachgezählt rund 30 koalitionsvorhaben
sind umstritten und kommen nicht voran
vor allem FDP und Grüne liegen im
dauerkind Patricia Wiedemeier Bericht
ob ihr Mantel ein politisches Statement
sei wurde kulturstaatsministerin Claudia
Roth zu Beginn der Klausur gefragt ja
aber schwarz
naja schwarz rot jedenfall glitzert der
Mantel ja er mag glitzern ein Statement
zur Lage der Koalition war dies nicht
denn hier glitzert und glänzt nur noch
wenig vor allem FDP und Grüne streiten
auf offener Bühne haben sich verhakt bei
zahlreichen Themen auf der Tagesordnung
stehen all die Streitthemen nicht
stattdessen ein Gast der kurzzeitig
ablenkt von allen innenpolitischen
Problemen
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
doch in der anschließenden
Pressekonferenz kommt der Kanzler nicht
mehr drumherum sich zur Koalition zu
äußern
wir haben viel vor um unser Land in die
Zukunft zu führen das sind ist mit
vielen Veränderungen verbunden und
deshalb ist es auch völlig normal dass
über diese vielen Schritte die
dazugehören sehr intensiv diskutiert
wird weil es ja einfach ist nicht zu tun
und die Augen vor den Herausforderungen
der Zukunft zu verschließen
herausfordernder ist dafür zu sorgen
dass man diesen Aufgaben gerecht wird
herausfordernd ist sie wirklich die
Liste aller Streitthemen
planungsbeschleunigung Waffenrecht und
pflegere Form um nur einige wenige zu
nennen also wir würden unsere
Koalitionspartner einladen nächste Woche
Gesetze zum Thema planungsbeschleunigung
bei Schiene und Brücken in der Deutschen
Bundestag einzubringen wenn man versucht
alles mit allem zu verhandeln dann
verlangsamt das natürlich Entscheidungen
bei der planungsbeschleunigung im
Straßenbau halten die Grünen dagegen und
Bremsen und deswegen habe ich daran
erinnert dass wir uns nicht in
ideologischen Graben Kämpfe verlieren
sollten doch ist nicht nur die
planungsbeschleunigung auch über die
Zukunft des verbrennermotors über
bio-benzin und vor allem über die
Finanzierung der Kindergrundsicherung
streiten Grüne und FDP ein digitales
Portal das ist ja das was für uns auch
vereinbart haben und da müsste die
Familienministerin jetzt auch liefern
sie hat ja zugesagt dass sowas kommt da
erwarte ich jetzt schon ein bisschen
Geschwindigkeit es braucht jetzt
tatsächlich politische Beschlüsse ich
habe die Grundlage gelegt andere sind
jetzt dran dass wir uns gemeinsam
einigen bei der Kindergrundsicherung
scheint es etwas Bewegung zu geben dass
deutete der grüne Parteivorsitzende am
Abend an appelliert zugleich an alle das
ist für unser allererste Haushalt von
guten nutzen wenn wir ein bisschen wenn
wir ein bisschen abrüsten nach draußen
und und den den Geister der
Zusammenarbeit den wir nach innen ja
miteinander gezeigt haben auch
tatsächlich
gut gelaunt zeitenwände und Zuversicht
heißt einer der Tagesordnungspunkte in
Meseberg noch versucht der Kanzler ein
erneutes Machtwort zu verhindern
und das Meseberg zugeschaltet ist und
Christian Lindner als FDP-Chef und
natürlich als Bundesfinanzminister guten
Abend Herr Lindner
hallo guten Abend Frau Slomka
brandenburgischen ist es heute ziemlich
frostig hilft denn diese Tagung dabei
dass das Koalitionsklima wieder ich sag
mal wärmer wird
machen sie sich um das Koalitionsklima
keine Sorgen wir haben viele sehr
wichtige für unser Land sehr bedeutsame
Fragen über die wir miteinander beraten
das wird noch seine Zeit brauchen bis
wir da zu Ergebnissen kommen am Ende
werden aber gute Lösungen stehen da bin
ich sicher naja also wenn man sich
zuletzt die neue Brieffreundschaft mit
Herrn Harbeck ansah wo man sich
gegenseitig quasi als sitze und Herr
Kollege und diverse Ironien um die Ohren
war kann man sich schon ein bisschen
Sorgen machen wie das Koalitionsklima
sich Moment so gestaltet auch angesichts
der vielen Streitthemen die es gibt
wenn man mir Briefe schreibt dann werde
ich die höflicherweise beantworten
richtig ist wir haben jetzt schwierige
Haushaltsberatungen wir sind in diesem
Jahr zur Schuldenbremse zurückgekehrt
aber unter Einsatz von Rücklagen wie das
auch beabsichtigt war im nächsten Jahr
muss die Schuldenbremse eingehalten
werden ohne Rücklagen ohne
Steuererhöhung und bei steigenden Zinsen
da muss nun priorisiert werden klar ist
der einfache Ausgang mehr Geld ausgeben
für das man Schulden macht der besteht
nicht mehr daran darf ich auch keinen
Zweifel lassen als Finanzminister denn
ich bin in der Verantwortung dass die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger nicht
durchwachsende Zinszahlungen und höhere
Steuern überlastet werden dann wird ja
nicht nur über Schulden machen oder
Schuldenbremse oder Steuererhöhungen
gestritten sondern auch über Klima
Themen wenn man sich da die großen
Streitpunkte der letzten Wochen anguckt
Heizungen Schienenausbau
priorisieren verbrennerverbot EU dann
hat man so den Eindruck die FDP ist in
dieser Koalition in der Hinsicht der
Geist der stets verneint
die FDP sorgt dafür dass unser Land auf
einem Kurs der praktischen Vernunft
bleibt Klimapolitik ist für uns eine
entscheidende Priorität eine
menschheitsaufgabe ja aber sie muss
sozial und wirtschaftlich auch
verantwortbar umgesetzt werden der
Klimaschutz sollte deshalb
technologieoffen sein sollte mit
wirtschaftlichen Chancen verbunden
werden und klar ist doch dass ein zu
frühes Verbot aller Gasheizungen
beispielsweise für die Menschen sozial
und wirtschaftlich nicht verkraftbar ist
macht auch für das Klima wenig Sinn und
gerade die klimafreundlichen
ökokraftstoffe der Ökosprit das brauchen
wir für die bestandsflotte im PKW und
deshalb sorgen wir dafür dass unser Land
auf einem Kurs der Mitte bleibt nur
außer der FDP sieht das nur wir sehen
das nur sehr wenige so also selbst die
Autobosse selbst der Audi Chef sagt
diese efuels von denen sie gerade
sprechen die werden keine große Rolle
spielen diesen ineffizient der ADAC
setzt sich nicht groß dafür ein und der
VW-Chef hat letztens gesagt naja also
das ist der bestenfalls noch eine
nischenrolle für Kleinserien Hersteller
womit hat wohl Porsche meinte
das wird man ja sehen ich sehe das etwas
anders ist eine Technologie Option die
synthetischen Kraftstoffe machen den
regulären Ottomotor oder auch den
Dieselmotor klimafreundlich ob und
inwieweit sieht das am Markt durchsetzt
Frau Slomka das entscheiden nicht sie
das entscheiden nicht ich das
entscheiden die Kundinnen und Kunden und
die Hersteller in den nächsten Jahren
und Jahrzehnten weltweit wird mit
Sicherheit der Verbrennungsmotor noch
eine große Rolle spielen und ich bin der
Überzeugung dann sollten die besten
klimafreundlichsten effizientesten
Verbrennungsmotoren von deutschen
Herstellern gebaut werden genau aber die
deutschen Hersteller Technologie
Freiheit setzen wir uns ein die
deutschen Hersteller sagen ja selbst
also exklusive Neuwagen die wird nicht
geben und in Brüssel ist von einer Lex
Porsche die Rede und weiß man ja auch
dass sie Porsche Fan und Liebhaber sind
man ist das ist das nicht irgendwie ein
bisschen peinlich die ganze EU
aufzuhalten für so ein kleines Segment
Deutschland
alleine könnte ja Gesetzgebung nicht
aufhalten es sind einige andere Länder
große Länder auch die hier Bedenken
haben
sich von Deutschland Hersteller
ja ich halte das sehr gerne aus Frau
Slomka jawohl es ist so die FDP sorgt
dafür dass wir technologiefreiheit bei
den autoantrieben behalten
Hersteller die das nicht nutzen wollen
haben damit ja keine Verpflichtung
Kundinnen und Kunden sollen und werden
Elektrofahrzeuge kaufen da wo es
gewünscht oder notwendig ist soll es
weiter Optionen in den 30er Jahren geben
wer das nicht gut findet darf uns gerne
kritisieren die FDP hat jedenfalls zu
keinem Zeitpunkt während der letzten
fünf Jahre ein Zweifel daran gelassen
wie ihre Haltung ist und diese Haltung
bringen wir jetzt sehr konstruktiv ins
Regierungshandeln ein wichtig wenn
natürlich das auch die Wähler Sie gut
finden also sie sagten dass er selbst
sie waren da konsequent als die
Autofahrer FDP vor allen Dingen für
verbrennermotoren und für Autofahrer die
schnell über die autobahnrasen wollen
aber es hat ihnen jetzt in den letzten
Landtagswahlen überhaupt nichts gebracht
im Gegenteil die gegen alle gründlich
verloren
wir machen Politik aus Überzeugung Frau
Slomka sie werden mich nicht davon sie
werden nicht davon nicht abbringen dass
technologiefreiheit und das der
marktwirtschaftliche Wettbewerb immer
besser ist als Entscheidungen vom grünen
Tisch wir können schlicht heute nicht
wissen wie ist die
zukunftsweisendste Technologie in den
30er Jahren das können wir schlicht
nicht wissen wir sollten uns deshalb
Entwicklungsphase nicht verbauen dafür
stehen wir Freien Demokraten wenn sie
schon auf dieses parteipolitische Niveau
bringen möchten und dafür kann man uns
kritisieren jedenfalls wusste jeder Mann
und jeder Frau woran man bei uns ist
denn das vertreten wir seit vielen
Jahren danke für das Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen trotzdem
haben wir am späten Nachmittag
aufgezeichnet und jetzt geht's erstmal
mit den Nachrichten weiter und zunächst
eine hoffnungsvollen eins danach
jahrelang in Verhandlungen haben sich
die Mitgliedstaaten der UN auf ein
Abkommen zum Schutz der Weltmeere
geeinigt Bundesumweltministerin Lemke
sprach von einem historischen Erfolg das
bei einer Konferenz in New York
erreichte Abkommen soll unter anderem
den Schutz der Artenvielfalt in
hochseegebieten verbessern also in den
Meeresgebieten außerhalb nationale
Grenzen das sind etwa zwei Drittel der
Ozeane
in Estland waren heute knapp eine
Million Wahlberechtigte aufgerufen ein
neues Parlament zu wählen Umfragen sehen
die liberale Reformpartei von
Ministerpräsidentin colors vorne im
Mittelpunkt des Wahlkampfs stand vor
allem Russlands Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine und dessen Auswirkungen auf den
nationale Sicherheit die seit 2021
amtierende Callas gilt als entschiedene
Unterstützerin der Ukraine erste
Ergebnisse werden in der Nacht erwartet
in Frankfurt am Main und in Mainz waren
heute Oberbürgermeisterwahlen in Mainz
gewann der parteilose Bewerber nino
Haase in der Stichwahl gegen den Grünen
Kandidaten Christian Währing und wird
damit neuer ob der rheinland-pfälzischen
Landeshauptstadt in Frankfurt hat die
heutige erste Runde noch keine
Entscheidung gebracht sie wird auch in
einer Stichwahl fallen in drei Wochen
nach dem vorläufigen Ergebnis zwischen
dem früheren bürgermeister Uwe Becker
CDU und dem planungsdezernenten Mike
Josef SPD
die Stiftung neue Synagoge Berlin
Zentrum judaicum ist mit der buberosen
zweigmedaille ausgezeichnet worden damit
werde der Beitrag der Stiftung zur
Berliner Stadtgeschichte und zu einer
friedlichen und pluralen Gesellschaft
geehrt hieß es bei der Verleihung im
Rahmen der Eröffnung der Woche der
Brüderlichkeit in Erfurt die Medaille
ist nach den jüdischen Philosophen
Martin Buber und Franz Rosen Zweig
benannt sie wird jährlich für die
Verständigung zwischen Christen und
Juden verliehen
in gewisser Hinsicht hat China
innenpolitisch eine ähnliche Entwicklung
genommen wie Russland so jetzt zeigten
gab es in Moskau zwar auch immer den
einen starken Mann an der Spitze aber
immerhin umgeben von einem Politbüro in
dem durchaus auch diskutiert und sogar
entmachtet wurde heute gibt es nur noch
den ewigen Putin ähnlich in China seit
dem Ende der maoherschaft gab es
unterschiedliche Fraktionen innerhalb
der Kommunistischen Partei die
ausbalanciert wurden und
institutionalisierte Wechsel an der
Spitze damit ist es vorbei
geltende Amtszeit und Altersbegrenzungen
hinweggesetzt und ist zum absoluten
Herrscher geworden auch über den
Nationalen Volkskongress der heute
begann
Steiner berichtet aus Peking
was aussieht wie das größte Parlament
der Welt ist ein scheinparlament das
abnickt was die kommunistische Führung
vorlegt
der Taktgeber des Volkskongresses ist
der Delegierte mit der Nummer
er wird sich hier seine historische
dritte Amtszeit als Präsident bestätigen
lassen hier den Ping baut seine Macht
weiter aus
[Musik]
dazu gehört das premier Liquid young zum
10 und letzten Mal den Arbeitsbericht
der Regierung vorlegt
offiziell sieht er der zwei Jahre jünger
ist als ich aus Altersgründen zurück
allerdings gehört er auch nicht zum
Skilager im Gegensatz zu dem Mann der
sein Nachfolger wird lizian dass der
frühere Parteichef von Shanghai die
Einwohnerinnen und Einwohner der
Hafenstadt im Frühjahr 2020 zwei Monate
lang in ihren Wohnungen einsperrte und
für die teils chaotischen Zustände
verantwortlich war schadete ihm nicht
alle anderen in der in der
spitzenführung sind alles Leute die mehr
oder weniger Royale zu schießen also hat
er das komplette die komplette
Führungsriege einmal ausgetauscht
obwohl die Staatsführung vor zwei Wochen
den großen Sieg über das Coronavirus
verkündete müssen die Delegierten Maske
tragen und dürfen sich nur zwischen
Halle und Quarantäne Hotel bewegen
die Auswirkungen der Pandemie lassen
sich auch am Wachstumsziel ablesen 5%
einer der niedrigsten Werte seit
Jahrzehnten hauptsache die
Wirtschaftszahlen gehen endlich wieder
weiter nach oben
das zweite wichtige Thema heute Chinas
Armee der Etat wird um mehr als 7%
erhöht mit klarem Auftrag
die militärische Führung stärken die
nationale Verteidigung und die militäre
Form konsolidieren und die Entwicklung
beschleunigen
draußen auf Pekings Straßen gibt es an
jeder Straßenecke auf jeder
Fußgängerbrücke Sicherheitsleute
während des Kongresses darfst du hier
kein Foto machen filmin ist hier
verboten genauso beschränkt ist der
Zugang für Journalistinnen und
Journalisten zur Halle aus demokratisch
regierten Staaten durften nur sehr
wenige dabei sein das ZDF genauso wie
die ARD und viele andere nicht
es soll ein Volkskongress ganz nach hieß
Geschmack werden alles unter Kontrolle
die Entwicklung in China verheißt
jedenfalls nichts Gutes in dieser
weltpolitischen Epoche in dieser
Zeitenwende der russische Angriffskrieg
zerstört die Ukraine die sich gegen ihre
Vernichtung wehrt aber er hat ja auch
Folgen für ganz Europa Christian Sievers
und Alissa jung haben in den letzten
Wochen für uns Menschen porträtiert die
diese zeitenwände gerade zu
personifizieren im vierten Teil dieser
Reportage Reihe sind sie nach Finnland
gereist und trafen dort den
Oberkommandierenden der finnischen
Streitkräfte general Timo
angesichts der über 1000 Kilometer
langen Grenze zu Russland und ihren
Erfahrungen mit diesem Nachbarn blieben
die finden immer sehr viel
misstrauischer gegenüber Moskau als die
Westeuropäer und sind nun sogar bereit
in die NATO einzutreten
sie üben hier den Häuserkampf
diese Einheit soll Finnlands Hauptstadt
verteidigen Helsinki schützen vor einem
Angriff
sie üben unter den Augen ihres
verteidigungsschefs die Richtung stimmt
schon meint der aber es gibt ja noch
mehr Training
angetreten vor Finnlands einzigem vier
sterne-general timo kiwinen ist oberster
Militär Herr über eine Armee die im
Notfall fast eine Million Reservisten
einziehen kann das ist jeder sechste
Einwohner
in unserer Geschichte gab es mehrere
Kriege mit Russland der Sowjetunion wir
wissen alle unser Nachbar ist eine
starke Macht und wir müssen bereit sein
das Land zu verteidigen Advent
in Umfragen sagt eine große Mehrheit der
Finnen regelmäßig sie würden auch selbst
mit der Waffe dafür kämpfen praktisch
jede und jeder hier hat jemanden in der
Familie der Wehrpflicht leistet oder
geleistet hat
rechter Fuß nach hinten sicherer Stand
leicht nach vorne beugen und dann tust
du was du tun musst
in den 90er Jahren hatten wir auch bei
uns eine Diskussion und wir wie die
meisten Staaten in Europa unsere
Landesverteidigung abbauen sollten aber
wir waren klug genug dass nicht zu tun
und jetzt zahlt sich das aus
200 Leopard Panzer hat der General
aktuell zur Verfügung und mit dem
Dienstwagen könnte er auch unterirdisch
fahren denn halb helsinki ist ein
einziger Bunker
hämisch wirken mit Blick auf den Zustand
der Bundeswehr will der Finne aber auf
keinen Fall nur Zweifel an der eigenen
Verteidigungsfähigkeit wie in
Deutschland soll es eben auch nicht
geben Ruhe und Sicherheit verkörpern das
erwarten Sie hier von ihm
denn der Nachbar im Osten ist nah gerade
mal zwei Stunden Fahrt von Helsinki bis
zur russischen Grenze über zunehmend
verweiste Autobahnen es ist ruhig
geworden am Kontrollposten seit Finnland
russische Touristen nur noch in
Ausnahmefällen ins Land lässt die Duty
Free Geschäfte für Besucher aus dem
Osten längst geschlossen
Finnland hat im Zweiten Weltkrieg ein
Zehntel seines Territoriums an dieser
wird Union verloren die Menschen hier
haben viel erlebt
manchmal versuchen Russen hier rüber zu
kommen aber sie werden wieder
zurückgeschickt
über 1.300 Kilometer lang ist die
gemeinsame Grenze das ist so weit wie
von Hamburg nach Rom
gleiche hinten bei den Bäumen nur ein
paar Meter weiter beginnt Russland es
gibt viele Schilder hier betreten
verboten aber keinen Zaun wirklich
befestigt ist diese Grenze nicht
bloß nichts provozieren strikte
Neutralität das war jahrzehntelang das
finnische Rezept jetzt empfängt der
General die Botschafter der NATO-Staaten
in seiner Kaserne
für Finnland eine historische Zäsur
wir hatten erwartet dass die Diskussion
um einen NATO-Beitritt hochkocht aber
dass sich die öffentliche Meinung dazu
so schnell ändern würde das hätte
niemand gedacht
mittlerweile ist eine große Mehrheit in
Parlament und Bevölkerung für den
NATO-Beitritt Verteidigung geht uns alle
an steht auf den Armee Plakaten wir
wollen niemanden bedrohen sagt general
kiwinnen aber mit der NATO gibt es mehr
abschreckungspotenzial und Russland so
ergänzt er dann noch verstehe ja
offenbar nur harte macht die Teams
noch mal weiter mit dem Sport an diesem
Wochenende und zuerst zur
Fußball-Bundesliga zu den Spielen von
heute bayer Leverkusen hat vier zu eins
gegen Hertha BSC gewonnen Wolfsburg und
Eintracht Frankfurt trennten sich
unentschieden zwei zu zwei
die Formel 1 ist in die neue Saison
gestartet in Bahrain gewonnen hat
Weltmeister Max Verstappen vor serches 3
Fernando Alonso mit großem Jubel
wer kam gar nicht mehr raus aus dem
feiermodus mit 41 Jahren wieder auf dem
Podest das Wein zuletzt von 9 Jahren im
Ferrari gelungen und so spielt der
Spanier dem souveränen Weltmeister und
Tages Sieger Max Verstappen die Show
Verstappen fährt bis auf einen
Boxenstopp immer vorneweg Charlie clair
muss an Position drei liegen mit
hydraulikproblemen aufgeben Glück gehört
dem tüchtigen Alonso sieht seine Chance
er zieht mit seinem ersten Martin am
zweiten Ferrari Piloten Carlos Seins
vorbei erobert Platz 3 Nico Hülkenberg
verliert die positionskampf ein
frontflügelteil und fällt von Rang 10
zurück wird 15 dominierend aber sind die
Red Bull Verstappen 1
Fischschwärme faszinieren seit jeher für
Taucher gibt es kaum etwas Schöneres als
in solche Schwärme hineinzugleiten und
sich von ihnen umfangen zu lassen nur
sollte man aber nicht an Frank Schätzing
denken sonst könnte eine mullmilch
werden als sein Welt Bestseller der
Schwarm 2004 erschienen war bald davon
die Rede dass das ein Stoff ist der nach
Verfilmung gerade zu schreit die
Geschichte einer unbekannten Schwarm
Intelligenz im Meer die sich gegen die
Zerstörung ihres Lebensraums wird
es hat dann aber noch fast zwei
Jahrzehnte gedauert bis das Buch
tatsächlich verfilmt wurde als
Fernsehserie für das ZDF in einer
internationalen Co-Produktion darüber
berichtet Claudio Armbruster und
natürlich auch über die Kritik die Frank
Schätzing geäußert hat
es ist so eine Sache mit den
Literaturverfilmungen wie oft wohl viel
auf dieser Welt schon der Satz das Buch
war besser weil die Bilder im Kopf eben
andere sind als die auf dem Bildschirm
[Musik]
Literaturverfilmungen sind ein Wagnis
besonders bei Frank schätzingsschwarm
der galt als unverfilmbar 900 Buchseiten
voller Wissenschaft unbekannter
Lebensformen und Katastrophen
er hat ihn trotzdem verfilmt Frank
Dölger der Macher von Game of Thrones er
hat also Erfahrung mit
Literaturverfilmungen
wenn diese Verfilmung Erfolg haben soll
dann muss sie für alle funktionieren für
die Menschen die das Buch gelesen haben
und für die die es nicht gelesen haben
jedes Medium hat seine eigenen Regeln
Anforderungen und Erwartungen und ich
denke die erfolgreichsten
Buchverfilmungen sind die die nah an
Geist und Seele des Romans bleiben
Frank Schätzing hat pünktlich zur
Premiere der Serie seinen Unmut
verkündet er vermisst unter anderem die
aktuellen sozialen und geopolitischen
Entwicklungen
allerdings müssen wir Rechnung tragen
und allen voran der Klimabewegung den
Aktivistinnen und Aktivisten die ihr
heute unsere Zeit prägen und wenn wir
den Schwarm in die Gegenwart von heute
Betten wollen dann kommen wir an der
Rolle Chinas nicht vorbei die großen
Player heute in der Welt sind die USA
China in ihrem konkurrierenden
hegemonialstreben und natürlich auch
Europa Russland das konnte man noch
nicht wissen und die unglaubliche Macht
das Internet Fake News gegen Fakten all
das hätte reingehört
wir mussten uns von Ideen trennen und
ich denke das trug zur Verbesserung der
Verfilmung bei wir waren nicht immer
einer Meinung Frank Schätzing und ich es
gab lebhafte Gespräche vieles mochte er
vieles jedoch auch nicht die Zuschauer
werden entscheiden ob es Ihnen gefällt
oder nicht das Schwierigste an der
Verfilmung war die Wissenschaft zu
vereinfachen
die Dreharbeiten 2021 in einem riesigen
wasserfilmstudio nahe Brüssel mit an
Bord die Meeresbiologin antibius als
wissenschaftliche Beraterin der
schwarmproduktion
für mich war faszinierend jetzt diese
neuen Geschichten
und andere kennen zu lernen gegenüber
dem Buch sind viele der der Helden sind
jetzt Frauen aus aller Herren Länder
sozusagen die da zusammenkommen und uns
Überleben kämpfen
das ist Methanhydrat
Feuer Eis tote Algen sinken runter auf
den Meeresboden und wenn sie zersetzt
werden entsteht Methan das unter Druck
gefriert manchmal lösen sich einzelne
Stücke und steigen an die Oberfläche
ich erwarte von so einer Serie die viele
Menschen schauen dass sie so mitten
reingeworfen werden in diese große Frage
wie kommen wir eigentlich weiter wie wie
finden wir den Einklang mit der Natur
der für alles Leben auf der Erde auch
dass menschliche Überleben essentiell
ist
genau das kann diese Serie liefern
Unterhaltung Spannung
und
Denkanstöße für die Zukunft von Mensch
und mehr
am Montag um 20:15 Uhr wird die erste
Folge ausgestrahlt online können Sie
sich in unserer Mediathek aber sie schon
jetzt ansehen und damit sind wir fast am
Ende unserer Sendung aber natürlich
nicht ohne unseren sonntaglichen
Ausblick auf die nächste Woche Anna
Kleiser gibt die Vorschau auf einige
Ereignisse von denen wir heute schon
wissen das über sie berichtet wird
[Musik]
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius wird zu
Beginn der Woche Bundeswehrsoldaten und
Soldaten in Litauen besuchen Deutschland
führt den nato-verband der dort seit
2017 den Ernstfall trainiert eine
zusätzliche kampfbrigade verstärkt
aktuell ein verteidigungsmanöver am
Dienstag sind politische Gespräche
geplant
am Mittwoch werden weltweit Frauen für
ihre Rechte auf die Straßen gehen ein
Schwerpunkt wird dieses Jahr die
Solidarität mit den Frauen im Iran sein
in Berlin sind Kundgebungen vor der
iranischen Botschaft geplant
die Aufnahme von Schweden und Finnland
in die NATO wird noch immer durch die
Türkei blockiert am Donnerstag werden
die Länder in Brüssel wieder miteinander
verhandeln es wird jedoch nicht mit
einem Durchbruch gerechnet für den
Beitritt fehlt neben der Türkei noch die
Ratifizierung durch Ungarn
am Samstag werden die Weichen für eine
Reform der katholischen Kirche in
Deutschland gestellt der Synodale Weg
wird zu Ende gehen es werden
Richtungsentscheidungen zu Sexualmoral
Frauen in der Kirche und zur Segnung
homosexueller Paare erwartet der Vatikan
lehnt tiefgreifende Veränderungen ab
und noch die eher ungemütlichen
Wetteraussichten zum Start in die neue
Woche morgen gibt es viele Wolken nur im
Nordosten locker des Gebiets Weise auf
über der Mitte fällzeit weil sie regen
und Schnee von Niedersachsen bis nach
Brandenburg auch kräftiger bei ein bis
sieben Grad am Dienstag ist es im Norden
stürmisch über der Mitte fällt längere
Zeit Schnee ab Mittwoch wird es im Süden
sehr nass und über der Mitte gibt es
weitere Schneefälle die Höchstwerte
liegen zwischen zwei und zehn Grad
in diesem Sonntagabend morgen freuen
sich hier Christian Sievers und Hanna
Zimmermann auf sie und um 09:25 gibt es
die nächste heute Express auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]